[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute zeige ich euch, wie ihr diese Cupcakes,
die perfekt auf einen Hochzeitstisch passen,
ganz einfach und vor allem schnell zubereiten könnt.
Ihr seht, ich habe sie mit Rosenblättern dekoriert
und das sind keine echten Rosenblätter,
sondern gemacht aus Obladen, d.h., aus Esspapier.
Sie schmecken aber nach Rose,
weil ich das Ganze mit Rosenwasser verfeinert habe.
Das Grundgerüst ist praktisch der Muffin hier unten,
darüber eine Vanille-Creme und dann die Rosenblätter.
Ich finde, die sind einfach immer schnell gemacht,
passen perfekt auf einen Hochzeits- oder Geburtstagstisch
oder auch mal so, wenn man sonntags
oder auch an einem anderen Tag einfach etwas Leckeres essen möchte.
Ich zeige euch jetzt erst einmal die Zutaten für den Muffin,
denn damit starte ich direkt und es geht wirklich sehr einfach
und ihr braucht nicht einmal großartiges Werkzeug dafür.
Dafür nehme ich 150 g Zucker, 200 g Mehl,
1/4 TL Natron, 1/2 TL Backpulver, 1 Prise Salz, etwas Vanilleextrakt,
2 Eier, jeweils 150 g Buttermilch und Sonnenblumenöl
und 50 g weiße Crispearls.
Bis hierhin ist es sozusagen ein Grundrezept für helle Muffins,
also einfach Vanillegeschmack
und die Crispearls sorgen jetzt für den Crunch im Muffin
und auch noch für ein bisschen mehr Geschmack,
weil es nach weißer Schokolade schmeckt.
Aber wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt ganz neutrale Muffins,
dann nehmt ihr einfach diese Zutaten.
Jetzt verrührt ihr einfach alles in einer Rührschüssel.
Denkt jetzt auch schon einmal daran, den Ofen vorzuheizen,
denn das Muffinsmachen geht schneller, als dass der Ofen vorheizt.
Ich verrühre immer ganz gerne erst einmal die trockenen Zutaten.
Man braucht auch kein Handrührgerät, also gar nichts dafür.
Und dann die übrigen Zutaten dazu.
Dann auch die Eier, Öl und Buttermilch.
Falls ihr keine Buttermilch habt, könnt ihr z.B. auch Milch verwenden
und einfach einen Schuss Zitronensaft,
einfach, dass ein bisschen Säure mit reinkommt.
Jetzt alles kurz verrühren.
Ihr könnt da auch Kaffee oder einen Saft nehmen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt die Rosen-Cupcakes machen,
dann lasse ich es natürlich neutral,
damit später der Rosengeschmack eben gut durchkommt.
Also ein Muffins-Teig ist wirklich der einfachste Teig,
den man machen kann.
Ich weiß, es gibt viele, die unterscheiden noch zwischen Muffins-Teige und Cupcakes-Teige.
Aber für mich ist ein Muffin einfach ein kleiner Kuchen ohne Creme
und ein Cupcake ein Kuchen mit Creme.
Korrigiert mich, wenn ihr wollt,
aber ich finde es einfach übertrieben,
wenn man bei Cupcakes sagt,
man nimmt jetzt einen Handrührgerät, bei Muffins nicht,
weil ich es unnötig finde.
Okay, und jetzt habe ich hier praktisch einen Eisportionierer
- den größten, den ich habe.
Damit kann ich jetzt gleich große Portionen
in die Papierförmchen reinsetzen.
Der Josh guckt mich gerade so ganz verwundert an.
Aber es war wirklich so.
Ich habe damals Muffins-Grundrezept gemacht
und hatte damals beim Grundrezept noch ein Handrührgerät.
Dann haben manche drunter geschrieben:
Nein, das stimmt so nicht,
weil man Muffins nur mit nur einem Löffel verrührt
Cupcakes macht man dann mit dem Handrührer.
Ich denke mir so mittlerweile,
man braucht gar kein Handrührgerät für diesen Teig.
Und ob jetzt eine Creme drauf sitzt oder nicht
- also… Ja!
JOSH:
Wenn man dann gut ist im Handrühren
und ein schlechtes Handrührgerät hat,
dann trifft es sich ja in der Mitte.
SALLY: Ja genau.
Und es ist einfach…
Für mich ist ein Muffin einfach ein kleiner Kuchen
und der Kuchen mit Creme.
Ja, man muss keine Wissenschaft daraus machen.
Und ich muss mein Grundrezept auf dem Blog einfach mal verändern,
denn das hier ist noch einfacher,
so wie ich es seit ein paar Jahren mache.
[Musik]
Es war immer so lustig.
Wir haben doch hier unseren ehemaligen Nachbar arbeiten, den Alex.
Er arbeitet mit meinem Papa im Garten
oder hat bis vor kurzem hier gearbeitet.
Der hat dann immer gesagt: Oh, wie heißt die Katze?
Dann habe ich gesagt: Muffin.
Dann hat er gesagt: Oh Martin.
Dann habe ich gesagt: Nein, Muffin.
Und er: Ja, Martin, Martin.
Dann sage ich: Nein, Muffin, wie ein kleiner Kuchen - Muffin!
Und er dann: Ja, kleiner Kuchen - Martin! [Lacht]
Egal, dann heißt die Katze eben Martin, habe ich gesagt.
Gut, und jetzt kommen die Muffins…
Oh, mein kleiner Muffin!
Jetzt kommen die Muffins in den vorgeheizten Ofen
bei 200°C Ober-/Unterhitze für etwa 20-25 Min.
Bei mir sind es tatsächlich fast immer ganz genau 23 Min.
Das kommt auf euren Ofen drauf an.
Macht einfach eine Stäbchenprobe danach.
Und während die hier backen,
kann ich euch schon einmal zeigen, wie ich Blüten herstelle
- essbare Blüten!
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Rosen werde ich heute aus Oblaten machen.
Ich habe sie ja neulich schon in meiner Tom & Jerry-Torte gemacht
und die Rosen kamen auch echt gut an,
Denn normalerweise mache ich sie aus Blütenpaste,
Blütenpaste, muss ich aber dazu sagen, schmeckt nicht besonders gut.
Also wenn ich Rosen aus Blütenpaste mache, dann esse ich sie nicht.
Sie isst eigentlich keiner - sie sind zur Deko da.
Wenn ihr Backoblaten nehmt,
also Esspapier im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes,
dann könnt ihr die Rosen und die Blüten auch essen
und man kann wirklich viele verschiedene Formen zubereiten.
Ich zeige jetzt einfach einmal so eine Basic-Form
und habe in meinem Video neulich, also bei der Tom & Jerry-Torte,
die großen eckigen Backoblaten genommen und sie zugeschnitten.
Jetzt nehme ich allerdings die kleinen runden einmal in 50 und in 40 mm.
Die sind nämlich schon rund.
Theoretisch kommt ihr dann auch ohne Zuschneiden zurecht.
Was ihr tun könnt:
Falls ihr sagt, ihr wollt es doch rosenähnlicher machen,
dann könnt ihr hier einfach so eine Spitze wegschneiden
und praktisch ein Dreieck erzeugen.
So, was wir dann noch dazu nehmen:
Entweder ihr nehmt Wasser oder ihr nehmt Rosenwasser.
Dann schmecken nämlich die Blüten auch noch nach Rose.
Und vielleicht habt ihr ja am Freitag
das Video von der Premiere gesehen:
Unser eigenes Rosenwasser.
Damit werde ich das jetzt einfach machen.
Bei Tom & Jerry habe ich das Rosenwasser auch benutzt,
aber das hat keiner gemerkt.
Das hat man im Video gesehen.
Falls ihr das Video vom Rosenwasser noch nicht gesehen habt,
dann schaut es euch gerne an.
Da oben haben wir es euch auch verlinkt.
Es ist wirklich richtig schön geworden.
Da nehmen wir euch einfach noch einmal mit in die Türkei,
auf die Rosenfelder in Isparta und zeigen,
wie einfach so ein schönes Naturprodukt entsteht.
Ein paar schneide ich jetzt hier zu.
Also einfach so eine Ecke wegschneiden,
sodass ein schönes Rosenblatt entsteht.
[Musik]
Dann besprühe ich das Ganze mit dem Rosenwasser.
Einfach so einen Hauch anfeuchten.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr gerne noch Pulverfarbe nehmen,
Lebensmittelpulver natürlich,
und so ein bisschen die Ränder einfach nur bemalen,
dass sie so einen Hauch von Farbe bekommen.
Oh, das riecht jetzt schon richtig gut!
Ich finde, später ist es dann der Hammer,
wenn die Rosenblätter dann getrocknet und fertig sind,
dann schmecken die eben auch nach Rose.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich diese Silikonprägestemple,
lege hier jeweils eine Blüte rein, und zwar so rum,
dass praktisch, wenn es geprägt wird, die Farbe innenliegend ist.
So kriegt man einfach noch ein bisschen Struktur rein.
Wenn ihr jetzt so einen Prägestempel nicht habt,
ist es gar nicht schlimm.
Ihr könnt sie dann auch mit einem Zahnstocher so ein bisschen einritzen
oder das Ganze weglassen und dann…
Aber hier kriege schon eine schöne und echte Rosenstruktur hin.
Und dann legt ihr sie zum Trocknen auf Löffel.
Am besten vorher mit ein bisschen Backtrennspray drauf
und dann so rum, wie ihr die Wölbung haben wollt.
Dann können sie bei Raumtemperatur trocknen
oder z.B. auch im Dörrautomaten bei 35°C oder im Ofen bei 35°C.
Dann geht es noch ein bisschen schneller.
JOSH: Du hast es Backtrennspray genannt!
SALLY: Ich habe euch getestet.
Okay, das ist kein Backtrennspray.
JOSH: Das ist kein Backtrennspray.
SALLY: Bäckerstärke!
Ich hatte es vorhin auch schon mal…
Da habe ich gesagt: Kann mir jemand das Backtrennspray geben?
Es ist Bäckerstärke.
Ja, ihr habt aufgepasst!
Ihr habt jetzt alle - wow!
Ihr seid alle Mitarbeiter des Monats.
[Musik]
Die Muffins sind ausgekühlt, die Blütenblätter sind trocken.
Ihr könnt übrigens, wenn die Muffins fertig gebacken sind,
die Restwärme des Ofens nutzen,
natürlich nicht direkt bei 100°C,
aber so ein bisschen auskühlen lassen
und dann die Restwärme nutzen,
um die Blütenblätter zum Trocknen reinzustellen
- gerade, wenn es noch so ein bisschen wärmer als lauwarm ist.
Passt perfekt.
Es geht aber auch im Dörrautomaten echt ganz schnell.
Die sind innerhalb von 20-30 Min. trocken.
Oder eben Backofenrestwärme oder bei Raumtemperatur.
Jetzt habe ich hier noch Zutaten für meine Creme.
Das Rosenwasser nehme ich gleich für die Muffins.
Dann brauche ich für die Creme 250 g Quark, 40 g Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt, 250 g Sahne, San-apart zum Steifschlagen
und zum Dekorieren, hier noch die ChocRocks in Weiß,
etwas Pulverfarbe und natürlich meine getrockneten Blütenblätter.
Also das Rosenwasser stelle ich jetzt mal dazu,
dass ich es gleich nicht vergesse, denn ich kenne mich:
Ich vergesse sowas dann einfach.
Dann nehme ich jetzt hier den Quark in meine Rührschüssel.
Ihr könnt auch eine Frischkäse-Sahne-Creme machen, wenn ihr möchtet.
Ich finde aber Quark-Sahne auch immer ganz lecker.
Und kurz verrühren.
Dann gebe ich die Sahne langsam dazu
und schlage die Creme damit San-apart steif.
5 TL, weil ich 500 g flüssige Masse habe.
Die Creme fülle ich jetzt in einen Spritzbeutel ein.
Da habe ich jetzt eine große Spritztülle schon davor gesetzt.
Ich finde, eine Spritztülle…
Eine Lochtülle passt jetzt hier ganz gut.
Ihr könnt ja auch mit einer Stern- oder Rosentülle Rosen aufspritzen,
aber ich finde, eine Lochtülle passt jetzt besser,
weil ich die Cupcakes eher minimalistisch halten will
und die Blütenblätter, also die Rosenblätter, sprechen schon für sich.
Deswegen finde ich schon eine Lochtülle ganz passend.
Ich hoffe, ich liege gleich nicht falsch.
Das kurz zur Seite.
Dann habe ich jetzt hier die Muffins, die gleich zu Cupcakes werden
Ich stelle sie jetzt ein bisschen enger zusammen
und besprühe sie einfach mit Rosenwasser.
Dann nehmen sie den Geschmack wunderbar an!
[Musik]
Man kann natürlich auch die Intensität des Geschmacks bestimmen.
1-2 Sprüher für einen leichten Geschmack
oder ein bisschen mehr für einen intensiveren Geschmack.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das so wird,
wie ich mir das in meinem Kopf ausgemalt habe.
Jetzt den Spritzbeutel oben zudrehen, schön senkrecht halten,
Diese Hand hier oben, also ich bin Rechtshänder,
drückt praktisch die Creme raus und die untere führt.
Dann machen wir mal einen schönen Tupfen drauf.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt erst einmal hier ein paar ChocRocks.
Das ist Schokolade, die schön als Dekoration dient.
Es ist einfach so Streu-Dekor, der auch wirklich gut schmeckt.
[Musik]
Also wenn das mal keine schönen Hochzeits-Cupcakes sind.
Jetzt hier noch noch ein paar ChocRocks und ein paar essbare Blüten
und dann passen die doch perfekt zur Hochzeitstorte,
die ich vor einigen Wochen gemacht habe.
Die dürft ihr euch auch gerne einmal anschauen.
Ach, ist doch schön.
Ihr müsst die Rosenblätter auch nicht rosa machen.
Es gibt ja auch weiße Lebensmittelpulverfarbe
oder ihr lasst es komplett weg.
Aber ich finde so ein kleiner Schimmer drauf ist schon schön.
Deswegen würde ich schon weiße Pulverfarbe nehmen,
mit diesem metallic Glanz.
Wow. Jetzt noch ein paar Blätter hier außen herum.
Perfekt!
Ein perfektes Hochzeitsbuffet, würde ich mal sagen.
Voll happy.
Vor allem geht es echt sehr schnell.
Sieht wahrscheinlich aufwändiger aus als es ist,
aber Muffins sind:
Mit Zutaten abwiegen hat man so vielleicht 10 Min. Arbeit,
Dann sind sie schon im Ofen.
In der Zeit macht ihr die Blüten, dann kühlt alles.
Also insgesamt wahrscheinlich eine Arbeitszeit von vielleicht maximal…
maximal 1 Stunde plus Kühlzeit 2 Stunden.
Ich habe es jetzt in 30 Min. Arbeitszeit plus Kühlzeit im Gefrierfach
- geht schnell. [Lacht]
[Musik]
Komm, Murat! Probier mal die Cupcakes!
MURAT: Ja, war schon lange nicht mehr da, muss man ehrlich sagen,
aber lag am Bau.
Aber jetzt sind wir bald fertig!
SALLY: Wie gefallen sie dir?
MURAT: Cool!
SALLY: Schön, gell?
MURAT: Richtig cool. Sehen auch aus wie echte Rosenblätter.
SALLY: Ja, ich finde, die schmecken halt auch echt hammermäßig.
Also probier mal!
Dann kommt der Rosengeschmack, aber nicht dominant.
MURAT: Cool! Darf ich jetzt probieren?
SALLY: Komm! Wir essen den romantisch zusammen.
MURAT: Löffelt man den? Ehrlich jetzt?
SALLY: Du löffelst doch gern! [Lacht]
MURAT: Okay. Ich bin gerade voll schockiert.
Mmh!
SALLY: Wir sind verheiratet. Das ist doch okay!
MURAT: Richtig cremig, ehrlich! Der Muffin ist auch echt cool!
SALLY: Ignoriert er mich gekonnt.
MURAT: Cool, oder?
Richtig cool. Cooler Muffin!
SALLY: Cupcake.
MURAT: Cupcake.
SALLY: Muffin - Martin!
MURAT: Unsere Katze heißt Muffin.
SALLY: Ja, ich habe vorhin die Geschichte mit dem Alex erzählt,
dass er sie immer Martin nennt, unseren Muffin,
weil er es nicht versteht - egal!
Ich finde es auch schön und vor allem schnell gemacht, sehr einfach.
Wenn ihr wollt, dann könnt ihr euch auch gerne
das Rosenwasservideo noch einmal anschauen.
Wie gesagt, Freitagabend lief es als Premiere
und da findet ihr einfach noch einmal alle Infos übers Rosenwasser.
Es ist einfach ein super schönes Video geworden,
wie alle, wenn wir unterwegs sind.
Ich finde, die Videos haben einfach so Kino-Charme.
Man guckt sie sich einfach gerne an.
Falls es euch ein bisschen interessiert, wie so etwas hergestellt wird,
dann schaut einfach einmal gerne rein und hinterlasst mir euer Feedback.
Ich finde es cool, wenn man sich Kosmetik auch einfach…
Wenn man Kosmetik einfach essen kann.
MURAT: … in den Mund sprühen kann.
SALLY: Ja, so ist es!
MURAT: Und ich rieche jetzt nach Rosen.
SALLY: Der hat mich gerade angehaucht.
Ist okay. Wir sind verheiratet. Wir dürfen das.
MURAT: Ja, alles klar.
Tschüss! Macht's gut!
SALLY: Tschüss.
MURAT: Sally, hör auf! Meine Mutter guckt zu.
SALLY: Ja hoffentlich!
MURAT: Nein, hör auf jetzt!
SALLY: Tschüss!
Die Rosenblätter!
MURAT: Ist das dein Wasser?
[Musik]